inventé au début du 20e siècle aux états
unis par le gymnaste allemand joseph
pilates est ce le pilates était à
l'origine une méthode de rééducation
pour les danseurs professionnels
la discipline a été élargi et est
aujourd'hui accessible à tous le pilates
c'est une gymnastique de renforcement
des muscles profonds dont principalement
au niveau de la sangle abdominale et du
dos donc c'est un une gymnastique qui
permet de travailler son renforcement
profond
sa posture et de gagner en force et en
souplesse qu'il faut aussi avoir
conscience que le pilote c'est une
gymnastique de rééducation vraiment où
on peut vraiment aider tous les corps
dans tous les états possibles a continué
de se muscler et à aller mieux ils sont
nombreux à y participer pour pallier des
problèmes de dos notamment comme j'ai
des problèmes de disques intervertébraux
dans le bas de la colonne la musculation
de la sangle abdominale est très
importante
et là j'ai vraiment une sangle qui me
maintient bien la colonne donc ça c'est
le premier point et de deuxième point je
gagne petit à petit en souplesse
moi j'ai choisi pilotes notamment c'est
parce que j'ai une courbe dans le bas du
dos donc en fait ça me permet de bien
comblé d'être bien maintenue en fait au
niveau de mon centre en bas mais plus
qu'une simple rééducation le pilates
peut être pratiqué à côté d'une autre
activité sportive pour se ressourcer
s'est notamment bien pour la danse fin
sam assoupli ça me détend c'est vraiment
top j'accorde est liée là je suis bien
en fait je suis détendu et ça fait du
bien intense oui mais pour la bonne
cause
mais attention le sport demande un
certain effort physique il y à
différents niveaux dont le cours avancés
proposant des exercices plus dynamiques
dans le pilates ya certains grands
principale le contrôler la respiration
mais aussi le rythme tant au point de
vue musculaire que cardiaque puisque on
a comme vous avez pu le voir on a
attrapé une bonne suée lyon on a bien
soufflé le studio c'est lines propose
des séances découvertes au tarif de 10
euros pour tester l'activité alliant
sport et bien-être